I do like to drink I've got a bit of a
problem I got really drunk last night
was incredibly hungover today had
another beer hangover went away in that
the amazing thing about booze the thing
that causes the problem is also the
solution I wish other problems were like
that you know like you have sex with a
girl she gets pregnant have sex there
again no more baby man that would be
amazing you know then you're guaranteed
to get laid at least twice you're
talking like whoo last night was
incredible we should that again no I
think we go home hey I'm just being
responsible I go a lot of bars my friend
actually works at a gay bar so I'll go
there from time to time get a free drink
maybe a compliment my guy friends are
blown away by this they're like dude you
go to gay bars that is weird if some gig
I ever hit on me I don't know what I
would do
how about you just not have sex with
them seems pretty easy sometimes I wish
I was gay seems pretty good you know
easy to hook up couple mimosas fix up a
neighborhood it's fantastic you know but
you know do like the ladies big fan of
the gals which is weird cuz when I was a
kid I hated girls when I was like six
years old I thought girls were gross
thought they were dumb and you know
you're allowed to hate girls as a kid
that's really the only group a kids
allowed to hate cuz if I was a
six-year-old that hated Puerto Ricans
that would be weird
you know I was like hey mom I hate
Puerto Rican she would never say oh
you'll like him one day
alright hey any Puerto Ricans here
alright too many Porto Ricans good
people good people uh very passionate
people a lot of knives but passionate
very fast hey I'm just telling jokes I'm
a comedian look like I live in New York
City alright if I was racist I would be
exhausted so I'll take it easy huh but
you guys are a great crowd some people
get so offended by these jokes the gay
joke the Puerto Rican joke I got yelled
at by a guy recently on the show this
guy comes up and goes hey buddy I'm gay
and Puerto Rican alright I don't
appreciate those jokes you know how hard
my life is
I was like whoa take it easy how hard
your life is dude you have the most
parades
yeah yeah I don't know race is always
such a touchy issue we're all so
uncomfortable or a race these days you
know especially white people we're all
scared of looking racist that's a big
fear we have like I was talking to one
guy at my last day job and I was like
hey man what's the name of that new guy
on the fifth floor the really tall black
guy and this guy goes whoa I don't see
color really did you really just say
that they really just come out of your
face so I looked this guy right in the
eye and I was like hey man it's cool I'm
black and he was like no you're not I'm
like
[Applause]
yeah you may not be racist but you are a
liar boy I'll tell ya I was the I was
the victim of racism recently I should
tell you I love Jewish women that's my
number one love the Jewish any Jewish
gals here all right hey love Jewish
women I was actually lucky enough to
date a Jewish girl for a while we talked
about getting married and her dad made
us break up cuz I'm not Jewish and I was
like come on really seriously like I
live in New York I have curly hair I'm
circumsized I'm a comedian I'm like
right there but still still he was like
no no my daughter will only marry a Jew
I want my people to live on out my
culture to live on Jews are all about
living on that's when I thought man Jews
must be really jealous of gay people
because gay people can't even reproduce
yet they keep popping up
that's amazing that's incredible no
other group can do that it's like a
superpower you know yeah like Jews are
sitting around like you got to marry a
Jew you got to marry a Jew and gays
alike we'll be fine
[Music]
[Applause]